do black people care do you care then a
pro driver said the n-word is the first
time I'm hearing about it right now is
it the way he said it
I'm called a white reporter in having a
press conference and there's a white
reporter in front of them Rose knows it
he says they hey I'm gonna say ninja
okay right if he goes that I'm gonna say
Carter hey white Carter well what do you
ask but he said the n-word I'd be
hilarious it would be [ __ ] hilarious
sometimes it's too funny yeah it becomes
too funny to be angry at yeah yeah it's
the end the fact if once you throw white
and wear it in front of it oh come on
come on
you guys should be able to say that you
could call another white person for
anything to do like when we open up the
studio again people like are coming back
here yeah like have people do their
confessional for their first n-word must
know that people have said it before
yeah right yeah yeah like you they must
know I think you all say it we go listen
to hip-hop and telex police's oh you're
no longer Coronas got challenged he was
leaning in to me to make sure I don't
say it I don't say it come on I don't
believe it we landmark keeps a real mark
says he says it I hope yeah we believe
that America is from France they don't
say if you're rapping along to lyrics
it's like just call say no in your body
then I won't say it but I'll say some
other [ __ ]
the same emotion
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you